[Music]
you might have another big movie in the
works are you playing flounder
it isn't confirmed yet so and you'll
have to see by me what kid wouldn't want
to be in a Disney movie I mean that
would be pretty cool that is 12 year old
Jacob Tremblay sorta kind of almost not
really confirming those Little Mermaid
casting rumors at the premiere of his
new comedy good boys last night the film
is produced by Seth Rogen and it's about
three middle schoolers gearing up for
their very first kissing party think
super bad junior complete with an
r-rating and only our nischelle Turner
was exclusively on set I think it's fun
to get to swear in trouble
don't let the good boys title fool ya
and indoor swing
in action Jacob et was behind the scenes
with Jacob in the gang as they shot this
dance scene in a mall what was it like
doing this dance number today in this
movie you can't kiss someone without
their permission remember from assembly
can I kiss you
I can see 12 year old Keith Williams and
13 year old Brady nude round out the
rowdy trio you took my bag don't get any
closer oh my god there's Molly in there
okay
who's Molly because she's not with us
has your mother said you say what you
need to stay here but let me hear that
come out of your mouth I was going in
for you can say that non edition and
afterwards you just pray to God I didn't
mean it as long as you're written for it
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
you